you guys how's it going happy tech
Tuesday today is it extremely exciting
day because I have been talking about
how forever I wanted to get one of the
robot vacuums and I used to have one in
my old old old apartment a long time ago
well I'm home my parents house and I'm a
penalty unblock the needle bought back
connected and I was reading and
apparently I'm connected to Wi-Fi and
your smartphone and all kinds of stuff
I'm so excited
oops step one he looks so cute he's like
a little robot you are my friend do you
want to be my friends what is this
telling me to do pull this button what
do I pull this oh okay off on okay look
at you you're looking like cute this is
great what's in here
probably all the things to make it work
you're an upgrade cable you look like a
little teeny tiny comb there's a lot of
parties here you might have to read the
directions here's the charging dot board
so this looks like if I recall from the
previous version that I had a human
before this is kind of like a little
magnetic type of strip so it'll block
off places where you don't want it to go
like down steps or wherever you don't
want it to go as much as I hate reading
directions I'm gonna read the directions
first things first the realist i'm
elderly i can't see this anymore what
does it say okay cool see it dirt bin
filler laser top cover this is the laser
top cover
okay oh he's doing things he's doing
what do I do now
holy Oh excuse you please open my dirt
bin and push switch to on he's talking
to me that's you annoy me we swing on
sorry buddy
just from angling you hear hello my name
is neato bop vac oh I'm super cute and
sexy you can call me what should I call
him guys he needs a name I'm not gonna
take responsibility for this whoa hey I
wasn't ready yet I thought was already
can you guys even
hey little guy how's everything going
for you he's doing a good job
here he comes what is that Maddie get it
get it Maddie get it he actually never
barks
let's clean up your dirt Matty
okay
okay so now I'm gonna download the app
because you can use this on your
smartphone to set schedules okay so
here's the app we're about to connect
this thing to Wi-Fi and so you turn on
the robot Wi-Fi my vacuum just created a
Wi-Fi hotspot this is incredible I'm
going to name it
piggy pie finalizing setup it says this
can take three minutes so we will wait
okay finally get a little bit set up and
I can basically do everything that I
want to do from my phone which is
fantastic so I can even go into the
settings you can schedule it you can add
days that you want to clean and if I'm
away traveling I can even set it from my
phone to go and start cleaning so that's
pretty incredible so here's my little
piggy pie let's just see what happens
I'm gonna hit ready to clean
this is great this is how I want to
clean it every day alright guys thanks
for watching you feel more information
on this awesome needle vac I'll put a
link in the description and now I think
I'm gonna just sit here and watch it
clean freaking love the future the
future is here Maddie come here honey
yeah you clean that up
well it's reading a new camera
don't worry it's going around it hahaha
maybe I can put the camera on top of it
this is great
no carried out
I'm confusing you little guy he's doing
a good job though going around
Maddi move it's going home it cleaned
the floor now it's going home look at
this wow it's a nice cleaning ol room I
just want to show you guys well look at
these nice patterns all through here it
went all the way out here it cleaned it
my mom approved look at that
let's check the dirt this is fantastic
alright guys I'll see you later all
yours okay it says thank you for
cleaning no no thank you
I'm gonna go take a nap cuz I'm
exhausted from all my hard work if you
tell me everything about your boss on
this sweater we are